what does discipline really mean you
know besides waking up early and how do
I employ it to all aspects of my life
what does it really mean yes
discipline it it does start with waking
up early it really does but that is just
the beginning and I always say that
discipline is the loop of all good
qualities but you have to absolutely
apply it to things outside of just
waking up early it's it's everything
it's working now every day making
yourself stronger and faster and more
flexible and healthier discipline is
eating the right foods to fuel your
system it it's about disciplining your
emotions so you can make good decisions
it's about having the discipline to
control your ego so your ego doesn't get
out of hand and control you it's about
treating people the way you would want
to be treated and doing the tasks that
you don't necessarily want to do but
that you know will help you or help your
team it's about facing your fears takes
discipline to face your fears so you can
conquer them and that's what discipline
is discipline means taking the hard road
the uphill road to do what's right for
yourself and for other people
it's so often the easy path the easy
path that calls to us to be weak for
that moment to break down for that
moment to give in to the desire and the
short-term gratification but the
discipline will not allow that the
discipline calls for strength and
fortitude and will it won't accept
weakness it won't tolerate another
breakdown the discipline can seem like
it's your worst enemy but the reality is
discipline is your best friend it will
take care of you like nothing else can
and it will put you on that path the
path to strength and health and
intelligence and happiness and most
importantly it'll put you on that path
to freedom